hello everyone and a happy new year as
many of you might know over december of
2021 toy animation claimed and blocked
over 150 of my videos this translates to
over three years worth of work being
removed from my channel that both myself
and my team worked hard to create
following those events i tried
everything from reaching out to youtube
support specifically to making videos
addressing it explicitly with all of you
guys helping to amplify my voice thank
you again by the way as it is because of
you that i have good and interesting
news to give today a lot has happened
since i last addressed this scenario
back in mid-december so i will be
filling you all in on everything that
has happened since and let me tell you a
lot has happened some really weird some
really good and a lot that i didn't even
know about as usual i will try to keep
this as brief as i can in mid-december i
released a video stating that i would be
stepping away from this entire situation
a lot of you found this abrupt and it
was however i assure you that it wasn't
a decision made for any other reason
than those stated in the video the
circumstances surrounding my videos
being taken down weren't the only things
that i had to contend with that month
i'm eager to share with you all the
details of my professional troubles
however i don't want to get into the
personal stressors that existed during
that time just know that they were a
large contributing factor that forced me
to take a step back
now onto some new stuff
following my last upload addressing this
situation on december 11th the very next
day on december 12th someone high up at
youtube who had requested i keep their
identity withheld reached out to me
personally on discord asking if they
could hop on a call with me from this
point on i will be referring to this
person as quote my youtube contact or
contact i immediately hopped onto this
call with the youtube contact and right
away they accepted responsibility for
this not being escalated sooner i had in
the past reached out to numerous youtube
support personnel through the proper
channels all to know success and to tons
of stress the youtube contact expressed
that this should never have been left
unanswered as long as it was and i'm not
gonna lie hearing a human voice that
felt both sincerely eager to help and
understanding of this impossible
situation felt like a weight lifted off
my shoulders and that's when they gave
me some information concerning the
situation i was not aware of my first
experience with this whole toei
situation began when i first received
those copyright notices via email
however my contact informed me that
there was much more to that story than
what happened after i received those
copyright emails firstly prior to any
email being sent to me toy animation
sent youtube directly over 150 takedown
notices these are requests to youtube
not to block my content but to delete
them off of my channel which would lead
to strikes right off the bat and likely
would result in the termination of my
account and that's bad but this is where
i want to give youtube some credit in
response to this request youtube as per
their policy did not remove the videos
but rather requested toei to confirm
that they had considered exceptions to
copyright such as fair use and fair
dealing in other words youtube looked at
my content and felt that the videos
might qualify for such an exception
courts have decided that copyright
owners must consider fair use before
they send a takedown and so they pass
the ball back to toei to provide further
reasoning and this is where this gets
interesting in response to this toei
broke youtube's policy and instead of
responding with a justification for
their takedown notices per youtube's
request they instead use their own tools
behind youtube's back to manually claim
and block each and every one of the over
150 videos in my catalogue of content
effectively achieving the same result
minus the takedown of my channel this is
what resulted in the 150 emails i
received alerting to me of this in the
first place so in short toei explicitly
broke the rules in this instance it is
important however at this time to point
out that had toei provided an argument
that the videos were infringing under
japanese law youtube would have likely
honored their removal removed the videos
worldwide and potentially struck out my
channel youtube's justification for
following this notice and take down
process ultimately boils down to youtube
wanting to retain their safe harbor
status if they lost this status they
would be picking aside and thus opened
themselves up to countless lawsuits from
all angles but in this instance toei
broke the rules of youtube's copyright
policy which made every single one of
those copyright claims and blocks that
toei filed against me
null and void
and this might sound great and following
this conversation over the days that
followed i technically had all of my
videos back under my control and
technically fully monetizable but as my
contact informed me we were far from out
of the woods yet they said that if i
were to put all the videos back up as
they were i would run a massive risk of
opening myself up to the exact same
thing happening again and perhaps this
time toei would provide that
justification they needed last time if
they did this then my videos would be
deleted and perhaps my channel too fair
use is a defense that makes sense in
most countries and certainly the ones i
broadcast to specifically however the
japanese interpretation of these
exceptions is less robust than most of
the rest of the world which is why i
made all of the claimed videos private
so that i could buy time to understand
my options over the next week my contact
jumped into a number of different
meetings and indirect correspondence
with the japanese youtube
representatives communicating with toei
to try and mediate some sort of
understanding initially they wanted to
see if it was possible to establish a
meeting between myself and a rep from
toei however the idea was quickly
discarded for a number of reasons
following this youtube asked
toyanimation to review all of my videos
they requested takedowns for since some
of them clearly didn't use any of their
footage and this is when something
incredibly surprising and concerning
occurred toei obliged and made a list of
86 videos that they said should stay
down with the implication being anything
that wasn't on this list could go back
up my contact shared this list with me
and asked me to review it and what i
found was honestly baffling contained in
this list were frankly the most
arbitrary assortment of videos i had
ever seen it honestly appeared as though
someone chose videos at random as if
chucking darts at a dartboard for
example my first video in which i drew
characters in a particular style was
included on this bad video list but the
second episode which had literally the
exact same style format and volume of
content wasn't to add to the confusion
some parts of my dragon ball review
series were requested to be taken down
while others which were part of that
same review series were not and to keep
in mind these are videos that were
edited in the exact same fashion as the
part which wasn't allowed the same is
true for my one piece series some of it
was to be taken down while others
weren't and as i continued reading this
list provided by toy animation i became
more and more confused so much so that i
wrote up a four-page document expressing
my concerns and the issues i saw with it
in the interest of transparency i will
read my closing statements from that
document where i reviewed the
aforementioned list to give you all a
taste of where my head was at the time i
was not happy
quote this is where i am going to stop
going through these videos simply put
either they're all okay or they're not
my most charitable reading of these
decisions is that those at toy animation
tasked with this assignment quite
literally have no excuse at this point
for producing such an incoherent and
incomprehensible list of unacceptable
and acceptable videos toei have in their
very own list demonstrated that they do
not understand the task or rules that
they are asking others to abide by this
list is rife with contradictions and
incomprehensible choices that i
personally find as both a head of a
household and a company deeply
disturbing if toei doesn't know the
rules of their own game that how can
they possibly justify this behavior
end quote and that's about as far as the
situation got before the holiday break
both in japan and america and there
wasn't any more to report until the
first week of january 2022
following this my youtube contact held
meetings with numerous other youtube
personnel trying to find some solution
to this existing issue i should make it
known at this time that i have never
spoken to toy animation nor have they
reached out to me personally at any time
everything i am telling you concerning
their actions comes via four degrees of
separation where their team communicates
with the japanese youtube team who
communicates with the american youtube
team who communicates with my youtube
contact who then relays all of that info
back to me however time and again
youtube would encounter the same
pushback from toei who i presume see me
as no different than the people who
upload the dragon ball films in full on
youtube they see me as a pirate
and in short
it appears to be that toei doesn't
believe that there is an acceptable
application of their content online with
regards to fair use which is extremely
unfortunate as i believe similar to how
video games have embraced the online
sphere i sincerely believe that a
collaborative or symbiotic relationship
between online creators and copyright
owners is not only more than possible
but would likely work extremely well for
both sides if they were more open to it
and the way that they're going it's my
belief that it will only hurt both
parties perhaps more so than they
believe is possible and look this is
just my opinion but i genuinely believe
that had it not been for team four star
and their dragon ball z bridge series
dragon ball wouldn't have remained
nearly as popular in the western world
during the time where not much new
content surrounding the property was
being released and that's not to slight
the works or efforts of official sources
they do an incredible job but is to
speak to the opportunity that's being
left on the table perhaps without proper
consideration with all that said that
left me in a difficult position without
toei willing to budge on the matter if
they were to file a lawsuit in japan
then in a japanese court it's possible i
would have little chance due to the very
narrow application of their version of
fair use and this
is where youtube did something they have
never done before
a move that has added a brand new step
in their copyright policy or protocol
and while this is a policy youtube uses
in other legal removal areas it's the
very first time they're applying it to
copyright
okay so
a legal copyright removal has to
consider fair use or other copyright
exceptions right my videos are delivered
in english and clearly are targeted to
those in the western world and so
youtube removed the videos in japan
because given their limited application
of copyright exceptions toei might see
this as infringing in japan however
youtube felt the videos could reasonably
qualify for a fair use exemption in most
of the rest of the world so the content
will remain up everywhere else until or
unless toei can make an argument that it
would not qualify for copyright
exemption in other territories in short
since japan isn't a demographic i even
attempt to target and didn't have the
capability of abstaining from uploading
to in the past
youtube has elected to block my videos
in japan so that if they wish to block
those videos in the future they will
have to do so in a country outside of
japanese law thus giving me what i
believe to be a fair chance and well
that's where we are now following the
release of this video i will be making
public all of the videos that were once
blocked and only time will tell what the
future will hold for my channel and what
toei may or may not do
my hope is nothing but given how
unpredictable this entire situation has
been
who knows what might and as i've
mentioned very well can happen but
something i do want to say is that while
i am perfectly willing to and have
pointed out in the past shortcomings of
youtube as a platform and supporting its
creators i will also point out
experiences i've had where without them
i would have honestly been lost this is
such an occasion youtube isn't one
entity it's a massive group of people
that have all different opinions and
backgrounds i can't speak to the quality
of everyone working at youtube but i can
say that the people i've been in contact
with over the last month following my
going dark on social media
have been some of the kindest and most
eager to help people i've ever spoken to
that have expressed a genuine desire to
help me have worked tirelessly to help
me find a solution in this almost
impossible situation and perhaps most
importantly i think their heart is in
the right place again i cannot speak for
everyone's experience with youtube and
their respective personnel and i have
been very very vocal about their
shortcomings particularly in this
situation early on and i still think a
lot of work needs to be done to make
sure something like this doesn't happen
again people shouldn't need to create a
storm to get attention but i think it's
also important to champion the good that
they do when they do it and in this
situation they sincerely helped me
greatly